[Music]
this summer witness yet another
spider-man origin story just so Sony can
retain the rights to the character Peter
Parker was just an attractive
intelligent likable athletic
well-dressed teenage loser but when he
easily walks into a high-security lab
one radioactive spider bite will give
Peter the ability to twitch like a crack
head break everything get every father
figure in his life murdered act like a
complete jerk every chance he gets and
stutter worse than Shia LeBouf in
transformers I wish I could just
embark on romantic journey with a
hottest girl in school falls for this
creepy stalker
he's got your on his computer proving
that love always prevails even when you
have gaping wounds that require
immediate medical attention immerse
yourself in the epic battle between a
hero who refuses to fight with his mask
on and a villain with the most cliche
origin story imaginable who is
conveniently connected to the most
important people in Peters life Curt
Connors that's the name of the guy in
the picture with your dad dr. Curtis
Connors
was also my daughter's mentors I think
you're talking about the one experience
the re retold story of an uncle who
strives to find yet another way of
saying with great power comes great
responsibility
that if you could do good things for
other people you had a moral obligation
to do those things that's what's at
stake here not choice responsibilities
as well as all of these other movements
that you've already seen before like
this a lot of this and more of this
[Music]
swing along with the smartest teenager
in Manhattan who uses the myspace of
search engines and does a terrible job
of hiding his secret identity
[Music]
seriously nobody thought that was odd
starry baby head Charlie Sheen's dead
Forrest Gump's mom detective Murphy
Makai rish the Geico gecko Octomom and
Lindsay Lohan if she had better parents
then not really that amazing spider-man
at least Kirsten Dunst wasn't in it
don't miss our future honest trailers
subscribe now and leave a comment with
something like to hear me say in my epic
voice baba ganoush it's time to kick ass
and gem bubblegum and I'm all out of gum
Rob Schneider is a carrot
c is for cookie My milkshake brings all
the boys to the yard Pikachu I choose
you